lucas giolito on for his 28th start
looking to win his 10th game his era of
369 a lot of strikeouts 180 158 in the
third
two-two take him out it's a high
fastball ohtani goes down
here's gosselin now with two away
gosselin jumps a ball out to left field
jimenez can only watch well ohtani
strikes out but phil gosselin who
brought only five home runs into the
game tonight picks him up a solo shot
one-nothing halo packy naughton who has
been great in two assignments as a
starter this year ballin two strikes to
count to tim anderson who's a strikeout
victim to start packy's night
and joan gets hit so he's 10th in major
league baseball and on base percentage
and he's on base again
he shook max dassey once
shook to another fastball and it's lying
harmlessly into center field
high fastball sinks rana hifo and one
gone
another one for you
struck him out
so when you come back from injury
striking out the side i would say steve
i'm not a pitcher is a good sign robert
batting sixth tonight hitting 344. here
comes the pitch there's a drive to left
and it will tie the game a long home run
for luis robert
you need to amend the numbers over the
last 27 games batting average getting
closer to 400
as louise robert he's that guy in your
lineup right now as opposing pitchers
you need to realize don't make a mistake
to him
ball's ripped to left field garcia drops
it in that's a long run for gosselin
leori's gonna think about two and
rightfully so he's on his way and he is
safe
it's a double right out of the box he
was thinking two and there's that smile
it's all in two for gavin sheets
on the ground left-hand side that
trickles through and garcia's coming
home
gavin sheets a chopper rbi and the sox
have the lead here in the second inning
pitch number nine to tim here
in center field that's down
ta is back in the lineup and he's one
for two
[Music]
slider dives out of the zone fourth
straight strikeout for geo
another swinging strikeout lagaris
disposed of
to left field malloy is back to the
warning track eloy goes up oh leloy
brought it in
eloy jimenez
reels in the ball and left and he's okay
how about that play
listen to the crowd for him lucas giving
him a cats off salutation we're probably
going to see that catch one more time or
so
but first this smoke to center field
base hit for alloy on two strikes
[Applause]
smashed again left center field of the
alley way it goes and off the wind trust
side
eloy hits a stop sign at third roberts
got a double with two out and leori's
gonna come up andrew wentz comes on it's
up for the sixteenth time is era touch
over four a lot of strikeouts so here's
garcia in a big early spot second and
third two out
up the middle
and off the glove of granny hifo it
brings in a run
garcia drives in jimenez three to one so
they're at first and third now with a
chance to get some more
that falls drilled and bring them all
home
another ball that nearly got to the
concourse
man does he have power
that ball for a little bit looked like
it was not going to come down
447 feet
there's ball four to phil gosselin who's
the only angel that's having success
tonight against giolito eight batters in
a row retired by giolito gets a one-hour
walk and jared walsh the next batter
walsh sends a ball well hit out to right
field garcia takes a look and that one's
gone
boy matt just like you mentioned he is
very very good on off speed pitches
walsh went down got it hits it out
jared walsh 27 home runs now 84 rbis on
the season
up the middle johan
is seeing the ball very well his command
of the strike zone somehow has gotten
even better
it's in and it's ball four it's jose's
second walk grand all left-handed
two-on-one away here's the pitch
and there's a base hit out into right
that ball is going to get the defense
monkatta scores abrayu to third and
brandall is going to be thrown out by
juan lagarus from right as he was trying
to stretch it into a double
mike right on for the eighth time his
era it's 386.
there's ball four and that doesn't
happen all that often a walk for fletch
three balls in a strike to ohtani with a
man at second and one gone and there's
ball four and that wasn't even close and
now he's three balls in a strike to
jared walsh
missed by plenty
struck him out
mike is loving life right now
some walks no harm big strikeout in this
game
oh my goodness robert goes down
thankfully he looks like he's okay as he
took a dive with that ball coming up and
in and here comes tony larussa to check
on robert
two and two
oh my goodness gavin sheets lays into
another one to right field and it is off
the wall this time
robert to third that may have gone
through one of the rings of saturn on
the way through
two one with one out
[Applause]
yep
robert's home
eight to three
a buck we got a bar and we got a run
and tim was the first guy that noticed
it i think tim pointed out
and bill welke took a look and said you
know what on second thought you're right
right there he juggled the baseball and
then he stepped forward without stepping
backwards yep
legares with a little dribbler to third
mon has got a hurry and it's too late
and the angels have loaded the bases for
the second straight inning
second base
hernandez and anderson back together
again reunited for two
and there's ball four
well the angels have had no trouble
drawing walks tonight
and marsh rips the ball into the right
field corner ren hefel will take the
turn and head into third base
to short tim and cesar cesar's turn
double play
jace fry comes on recently was recalled
02
struck him out chase frye beautifully
done
to second base hernandez makes a
beautiful snare and that'll do it the
sox win 9-3